Take a look at this scene
in 1961's "The Parent Trap."
It's pretty easy to spot
where the shot is stitched together
to make it look like Hayley
Mills is playing two twins.
Now take a look at this shot
from the 2019 movie "Us."
Lupita Nyong'o appears to be head-to-head
with her doppelgänger,
who's clutching her neck
as they grab each other by the wrists.
To pull off this scene,
director Jordan Peele
needed much more than a simple stitch.
But creating complex
twin shots like this one
required a lot of building blocks
over more than 100 years of innovation.
So, how did it happen?
Having one actor star in dual roles
was a popular novelty
in the silent-film era
and in the early talkies.
♪ Join the Navy band ♪
♪ When they play ♪
See this shot from 1898,
where the illusionist
Georges Méliès created
four moving versions of
his head in one frame?
It was accomplished with
the use of matte shots,
which were kind of like
old-school green-screen composites
created by blocking
parts of the camera lens.
It was with mattes that the
first split-screen effects
were pulled off.
This is the traditional twin technique
you probably associate
with "The Parent Trap."
You shoot the scene twice,
with the actor and a
stand-in switching places,
then combine the two
strips of film into one.
To disguise the seam,
filmmakers make use of
background elements in the shot,
like a doorframe.
You can see that in "A Stolen Life,"
with two Bette Davises.
Or here, where the
actor played twins again
in "Dead Ringer."
In these movies, you can also see the use
of the classic
over-the-shoulder technique,
where the actor speaks to a
stand-in filmed from behind.
Split screens got complicated
when one twin had to
interact with another.
Take this scene from
"The Prisoner of Zenda,"
where Ronald Colman shakes
hands with his identical cousin.
The filmmakers put glass
in front of the camera,
part of which they covered in masking tape
to matte out the head and
shoulders of the actor's double.
After filming the scene,
they ran the film backwards
and filmed it again with
the actor on the other side,
this time matting out
everything but his head and shoulders.
That's a lot of work for a handshake shot
that's only a few seconds long.
The split screen also
usually required filming
with a locked and fixed camera,
resulting in shot compositions
that could look very designed,
with a sort of butterfly symmetry.
So, how did you get from that
to a shot like this,
from David Cronenberg's
horror movie "Dead Ringers"?
In this film, not to be confused
with the earlier Bette
Davis movie "Dead Ringer,"
Jeremy Irons plays a disturbed
pair of twin gynecologists.
The movie was a big deal at the time
because of how dynamic its shots were.
In this scene, for example,
you see the twins walk and talk together
while followed by a fluid moving camera.
And a shot like this was only possible
because of innovations from "Star Wars,"
which, in 1977, was the first film
to extensively use motion-control cameras.
This was groundbreaking for twin effects
because directors could now program
precise, repeatable camera movements
to replicate the same
shot over and over again.
This helped visual effects
artists film clean plates
with no actors in them
and use those plates
to help merge people into
the scene in postproduction.
Motion control became a
mainstay of twin movies.
And in 2002, it was among
several techniques used
to create the 130 twinning
shots in the movie "Adaptation,"
where Nic Cage plays the
identical Kaufman brothers.
One way the filmmakers
made the effects invisible
was with green-screen composites.
That's when you film a
twin on a green screen,
isolate them, and comp them
into a shot with the other twin,
as seen here with the
two Seth Rogen characters
in "An American Pickle."
For this scene, Seth walked on a treadmill
in front of a green screen
so that when his two characters
were comped together,
they'd move at exactly the right pace.
In "Adaptation," the
green-screen method only worked
for about 20% of the twin shots,
mostly in the scenes
that took place indoors.
Outdoors, green screens can
create issues with green spill,
when that green light ends up
in places you don't want it.
In these cases, the
filmmakers on "Adaptation"
turned to rotoscoping,
which essentially means tracing by hand.
With the rise of digital
rotoscoping in the '90s,
the technique became a
major player in twin movies,
allowing artists to comp together elements
of different shots even
if they weren't filmed
in front of a green screen.
It's one thing to make
two versions of an actor,
but what about 80?
That's how many versions of Hugo Weaving
appear in the "Burly Brawl" sequence
from "The Matrix Reloaded."
No amount of motion control,
split screens, or rotoscoping
could make a fight sequence
with this many clones possible.
Instead, this scene took
advantage of digital doubles.
These CG humans were most often used
for wild stunt sequences
that no person could perform in real life.
Because CG faces can
look rubbery up close,
digi-doubles are best used for wide shots,
like those of the Agent Smith clones
in "The Matrix Reloaded."
CG humans are also super
expensive to create.
The "Burly Brawl" scene alone
cost Warner Bros. an
estimated $40 million,
a big chunk of the film's
$150 million budget.
So the digital-doubling method is best
for a single sequence,
not a workable option
for doubling an actor
throughout an entire movie.
Director David Fincher had to come up
with a different solution for
his film "The Social Network,"
where Armie Hammer played
the Winklevoss twins.
Armie and his body double, Josh Pence,
underwent a tailored training regimen
to make their bodies
as similar as possible.
To transpose Armie's
face onto Josh's body,
the filmmakers settled on
a facial-capture process
very similar to the one used
in video games like NBA 2K.
The VFX team first used
a medical-grade laser
to scan Josh's and Armie's
heads for digital models.
During filming, Josh wore
tracking markers on his face
so the VFX team could later object-track
his facial movements.
After, they recorded Armie
inside a custom stage,
which had computer-controlled
lighting settings
to match the light in every scene.
In this stage, an array
of cameras recorded
every angle of Armie's face to provide
what is called a face texture map,
which could then be used to animate
the CG model of his head,
which, in turn, would get
mapped onto Josh's body.
This basic process was also
used to clone Paul Rudd
for the Netflix series
"Living with Yourself,"
except Paul preferred to
act out his scenes alone,
reacting to his prerecorded
lines through an earpiece.
In scenes that required a
stand-in, like this one,
where Paul's character
resuscitates his clone,
the actor performed opposite
a guy in a green suit,
who VFX artists could replace later on.
The elaborate face-scanning approach
wouldn't have been as feasible for "Us,"
which follows a family of four
confronting their evil doppelgängers.
The film built on all the
innovations in twin effects
over the past 100-plus years
to bring this nightmare scenario to life.
With the advancement of face,
head, and body replacements,
technology could now be used
in a Dr. Frankenstein kind of way
to harvest different limbs and body parts,
a similar method used to create the clones
in many scenes from "Orphan Black."
From the start, "Us" required
a lot of stunt doubles,
including a photo double and a body double
for each of the four main actors.
One producer joked that
there could be six versions
of Winston Duke on set at a given time,
all dressed in Howard
sweatshirts and glasses.
Before shooting, Jordan and
the VFX team would figure out
which of the twins was guiding the action.
They'd capture that first
with the main actor playing the lead
and their double playing opposite.
Then the actor and
double would swap places.
After shooting, the VFX team
would patch the twin plates.
In many cases, they'd decide
to use a head from one plate
and track it onto the body of
the double in the other plate.
But often it got more complicated,
with artists piecing together by hand
various parts of an actor's
body from different shots.
Most modern twin movies and TV shows
use motion-control cameras
to smooth out this process,
but in "Us," the script called
for lots of handheld shots
filmed with a more visceral camera style.
Without motion control,
the crew had to take careful notes
of all camera motion in each scene,
marking every position and tilt
so they could replicate it
after swapping the actor.
There were also scenes that
the actors couldn't perform
with a real double,
like this face-off in the hall of mirrors,
when the young version of
Lupita Nyong'o's character
gets choked by her evil doppelgänger.
The actor, Madison Curry,
needed something to really grab onto,
so they had her clutch a
paper cup wrapped in green,
which would be digitally
replaced later on.
A similar technique was used in "Enemy,"
where Jake Gyllenhaal acted opposite
a tennis ball on a stick,
its height representing
his double's eyeline.
This method can make the
VFX team's job easier,
because it means there isn't a
whole body to erase later on,
as seen here for "Orphan Black"
and "An American Pickle."
None of these innovations
happened in a vacuum.
Even in 2019, "Us" relied
on some of Hollywood's
tried and true methods, like
the good old split screen,
for a number of shots.
Every once in a while on
set, Jordan Peele would say,
"I'm thinking this shot
is a Hayley Mills."
The dynamic twin scenes in his movie
were a culmination of more than 12 decades
of Hollywood ingenuity.